لا تزال اصداء الاحتفال بالملا الاول لسد
جورج وسوف تنزانيا متفاعله في القاهره
نجاح وتحالف الشركات المصريه في بناء السد
في الوقت المحدد ودون اي اخفاقات او تاخير
يراه البعض رساله سياسيه تجسد لعوده مصر
للقاره الافريقيه بعد عقود من الغياب
2014 بقوه الى الاتحاد وراسه الاتحاد
الافريقي واهتمامها في اطار التكامل في ما
بين مصر وشقها الافرقه لا غنى عنه احنا
دلوقتي شغالين مع الشركات المصريه اللي
لها تواجد في عمق القاره الافريقيه عشان
التغلب على بعض الصعوبات اللي من اهمها
ايجاد التموين في حاله ايجاد تمويل من
المؤسسات الماليه الوطنيه في الدوله
المصريه هيكون من السهل اختراق سوق
الافريقي في مشروعات مثيره ومشروعات كثيره
ان شاء الله ترى القاهره ان السد التنزاني
يمثل نموذج لامكانيه التعاون في الاطار
الافريقيه في التنميه دون المسافه بحقوق
الدول الاخرى في اشاره للخلاف بين مصر
والسودان من جهه وبين اثيوبيا من جهه اخرى
بشان سد النهضه الرساله الاساسيه لاثيوبيا
والعالم وافريقيا هي ان مصر لا تقف عائقا
ضد مشروعات التنميه في افريقيا طالما انها
لا تخالف القواعد القانون الدولي ولا تضر
بمصالح مصر واا السودان كما يحدث في سد
نهضه طالما انه لم يحدث هناك اتفاق ومن
المتوقع ان يولد سده ريري
215 ميجا وات خلال عام بعد اكتمال الملف
طاقه تكفي لتوفير الكهرباء للكثير من
المناطق في تنزانيا فيما يرى اخرون ان
انشاء سدود اخرى قد يوفر فائده من
الكهرباء لتصديره لدول الاخرى في شرق
افريقيا مشهد وانت تحقق فانه قد يفرض
معدلات سياسيه واقتصاديه جديده في القاره
احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره